Mm,
at a 100 mile run in San Diego and I was
running,
I was running this race as part of a six
person relay team with friends and he
was running the entire race by himself
and the run was unsupported so you have
to bring your own supplies.
So we had,
you know,
we overdid it a little bit.
We had a tent and we had misuses and
food.
I mean we were ready for like in case we
had to stay there a week and he had a
folding chair,
a bottle of water and a bag of crackers.
And I just thought to myself like,
who is this guy?
Never seen anything like it.
And during the race I kept an eye on
them and around mile 70 he weighed
probably 260 pounds,
which is quite large for an ultra
runner.
He had broken all the small bones in
both of his feet and a kidney damage.
And he finished the race.
So when it was done,
I googled them to fascinating life story
and I decided literally to cold call
them and I flew out and met with them.
And after sitting with him for a couple
of minutes,
I realized that I could learn so much
from a guy like this and what makes them
tick and various buckets in my life
would be so much better if a little bit
of what he had rubbed off on me.
I asked him to come live with my family
and I for a month.
So at the time that I invited seal to
come live with us,
I had an 18 month old son.
I was married,
still am two more kids since.
And I had sold a couple of businesses.
I was in a great place professionally in
my life,
but I was also in a routine and routines
are great but they can also be a Rut.
And I found that I just wasn't getting
better.
I was doing the same thing every day.
Like so many of us wake up,
go to work,
come home,
have dinner,
repeat.
And I just wanted to get off autopilot
and I thought that he would be a great
way to get in good shape,
but also to just mix up my routine and,
and get better.
The first day that seal came to live
with me,
he asked me to do.
He said,
how many pull ups can you do?
And I'm not great at pull ups.
I did about eight just getting over the
bar eight and then started to take 30
seconds and do it again.
So 30 seconds later I got up on the bar
and I did six struggling and instead.
All right,
one more time.
We waited 30 seconds and I barely got
three or four and I was done.
I couldn't move my arms done.
And he said,
all right,
we're not leaving here until you do 100
more.
And I thought there's no what we're
going to be here for quite a long time
because there's no way that I could do
100.
But I ended up doing it one at a time
and he showed me,
proved me right there that,
you know,
there was so much more.
We're all capable of so much more than
we think we are.
And it was just a great lesson.
Was actually the first thing that we did
a.
It was just a great lesson and we had so
much more than our reserve tank than we
think we do.
One of the things that seal said to me,
and it's in the book and one thing that
people have said that really resonated
with them,
he would say that when your,
when your mind is telling you you're
done,
you're really only 40 percent done.
And he had a motto,
if it doesn't suck,
we don't do it.
And that was his way of every day
forcing us to get uncomfortable to
figure out what our baseline was and,
and what are,
you know,
what our comfort level was and just,
turning it upside down.
The 40 percent rule,
maybe it's give or take a look at a
marathon.
Most people hit the wall at a marathon
at mile,
anywhere from 16 to 20.
And you know,
99 percent of the people in this country
that run marathons finish and they all,
predominantly all of them go through
this,
hit the wall.
So where does that extra 50 or 60
percent or whatever the number is come
from.
I mean,
it's their brain saying,
I'm done,
I don't want to continue,
but there will saying,
you know what,
let me get to the finish line.
So we all have that will.
It's just a matter of how do we apply it
to not just the once a year marathon,
but through our daily lives and make it
apply to a variety of things.